now who would you like to see ultimately
on that iron throne I changed my opinion
all the time you know so many people
have asked me this question and then you
know they expect one answer because I've
said it before and then I say something
else and they're like oh you didn't show
up for I don't really know I don't have
a clue every guy I don't have to make
the decision in the end because geez I'd
really don't know who would pick there's
so many fantastic characters but then I
know that George you know if it's
someone who you think will get to the
Iron Throne probably won't be so yeah I
don't know if someone who deserves it I
think so yeah but I'm not sure I
sometimes say Daenerys I think he's kind
of got the right intentions and she's
always been trying to get to the throne
and just because they were there first
really it's not for anything else I
think some people are trying to get to
get to the throne but for revenge or you
know just to see the look on someone
else's face you know not really for
themselves so I think yeah she's kind of
got the right intentions he's
interesting who spoke to Alfie Allen
recently as well and he said he'd like
CI a-- on the throne i think that's kind
of cool
i need to be a pretty good ruler but
he's just trying to get home really so
it's not really i guess that would be
cool
I think REO would be quite a good hand
but to the right King you know but yeah
I think she'd she'd do well in that area
and I know what you mean about not
changing your mind but he went on the
throne because we kind of changed our
mind about how we feel about different
characters of the seasons move on don't
worry yeah I mean Jamie Lannister for
one it completely shocked you know and I
knew that was kind of knew that was
coming in the script for you to because
mom said well if you wait till season
today she's read the books just wait
till Susan through you really get to see
another side to Jamie I was like alright
so I sort of knew that there was
something different coming this season
and we were in the read-through and I
think he's got a long bit of dialogue
and I remember flicking over the
painting I was like okay I'm not Yugi I
sort of follow along as I'm just gonna
watch you know and listen then and I
just you know you see a completely new
side to these characters that you've
always hated and never really given an
opportunity you never really given a
chance
yeah and I've actually kind of you know
please and your heartstrings a little
bit and yeah it changes up a bit and no
one's really comfortable with always
changes and
a new character involved or you know
this one's now body and a goodie or you
know it kind of it it keeps it
interesting it keeps it really
interesting isn't it and he's been
interact with a great female character
as well this season hasn't he Brienne of
Tarth and when Christie also had to cut
her hair as did you for the for the show
how was it when you had to cut your hair
so I believe that Gwen cried yeah well I
I get on really well with gray and we
have a lot in common we're both women on
the show who don't really get to look
glamorous and we both had to cut our
hair and we work with swords and and I
think yeah I had a lot to talk to her
about when I first met her and we both
had a long hair and we were like oh I'm
getting mine cut in two weeks and I'm
getting mine cut like tomorrow and we
were like ooh but I had already had
short hair and in the past so I knew it
suited me and I hair wasn't really that
long and I was kind of just like yeah
but I know going to struggle with it a
little bit but she looks fantastic and
I'm kind of glad she had it cut because
you know wigs are really uncomfortable I
had to wear one for series one so I yeah
I know that Hugh he would kind of regret
it if he didn't cut her hair so yeah he
looks fantastic so yeah and the it's
it's something that we have in common
because you know it's kind of odd when
you're on Game of Thrones there's a lot
of sex and nudity and stuff and being
one of the female characters this is
more sort of a masculine character I
think and um I think that's you know
different and everyone always thinks of
Game of Thrones like Oh with all the sex
and I'm like yeah well not my character
I'm kind of you know this is yeah you
know one of the biggest pom boys I've
ever played so yeah uh-huh we we both
have that in common
which of the other characters you'd
particularly like on the show if you
weren't a Lea for example who else would
you like to be well I think there's so
many great characters it'd be cool to be
a hated character Cersei would be quite
a cool character but I kind of like her
as well as it's strange
she's a complex character and then
Daenerys got a dragon that's her it'd be
cool to do some CGI and stuff because I
did work with the dogs but you know I
did that was so lost
so yeah yeah so we call to work with
them like dragon or not we were dragons
but you know to do that side of it but I
think Ygritte is really cool and she
comes out with it and is not afraid to
make people feel really uncomfortable
and I think that's kind of funny she
talks a lot of sense too so yeah it's
not there's lots of and they're all
female characters that I pick as well
she's very outspoken as well in a way
like iris he says he says what's on your
mind isn't she I know her line you know
nothing Jon Snow yeah exactly it's just
a memorable and I think she's um it's
kind of added a new side to that kind of
storyline now and it's a complication
maybe as Jon Snow's half-sister do you
agree that he knows nothing about some
things so half and half then yeah I
think I think maybe he knows more than
she gives him credit for but he's a
woman tell me a little bit about working
with your co-stars as you said you work
with so many people have I knew yeah
I've been really lucky in that Ari has
been it's very well traveled and I'm I
get to work with some fantastic other
actors and them it's just you know it's
the first job the first acting thing I
ever got and I've been extremely lucky
in that I've you know learnt so much and
met so many people and you know she's
making an impression and and different
things that come out of it as well and
and like if I go to audition or
something they'll say oh well I just
have this feeling like oh well so once I
was on that and I know him from this and
and it just gives like new connections
and things which is really important I
think in this industry and it's you know
really helped with all of that and yeah
I'm I'm so grateful for such a fantastic
role in such a fantastic series and it's
been a real kind of booster for my
future really and we love you in it as
well everyone does you had a massively
brilliant reaction fans and and
absolutely understandable to who would
you like to work with you maybe you
haven't worked with so far on the show
oh I don't know I think I kind of work
with a lot I mean if we call to do some
scenes in King's Landing like with
Cersei and Sansa and that kind of thing
but I didn't know how that would work
character wise because she probably does
end up killing Cersei I don't know but
you know it'd be cool to work with Lina
we have done a scene together but you
know her being that would be cool she's
a fantastic actress and yes a shame that
I don't get to see her more but yeah it
would be cool to see my family again and
do some scenes with like Michelle
because we never really had a one-on-one
scene or anything it was only a big
group scenes that we had together so and
just to see like how people are on set
really because you know you meet them in
downtime and stuff but how they work in
you know to watch them acting instead of
just on on screen that would be
interesting so I have to wait and see
what happens
you